Well, we've already learned a lot about electricity.
We know that negative charges like to be with positive charges.
We know four methods to charge an object,
and we've learned that the earth is both a source and a sink for electrons.
But one thing we haven't talked about at all—
one of the most important concepts in physics is energy.
Why don't we go back to Professor Fregonese and see what he has to say
about energy as it relates to electricity.
One of the most evident effects of electricity are attractions and repulsions
of electrified bodies and this is important because you can use these forces
to produce work, to produce energy.
We can start understanding it with an analogy with gravity, which is simple
because we have only attraction and electricity is much more complicated because
you have also this complication of repulsion.
If I have a body of mass, there is an attraction between the body and the earth
and there is potential energy.
If I drop this body, it has the capacity to produce some work
maybe to break a neck down there.
It goes down and the potential energy diminishes
and it acquires kinetic energy, movement, velocity,
and which is proportionate to the square of velocity.
With electricity, it's more complicated because of repulsion but the idea is similar.
You can use the interactions between electrified borders between charges
to produce work so to have energy to produce something.